the mystery of human existence lies not
in just staying alive but in finding
something to live for
[Music]
the best way to keep a prisoner from
escaping is to make sure he never knows
he's in prison
nothing in this world is harder than
speaking the truth nothing easier than
flattery
the darker the night the brighter the
stars the deeper the grief the closer is
god
[Music]
i gave up caring about anything and all
the problems disappeared
[Music]
it is better to be unhappy and know the
worst than to be happy in a fool's
paradise
if you want to overcome the whole world
overcome yourself
[Music]
if you wish to glimpse inside a human
soul and get to know a man just watch
him laugh if he laughs well he's a good
man
you can be sincere and still be stupid
the soul is healed by being with
children
[Music]
the more i love humanity in general the
less i love man in particular
[Music]
nothing is easier than to denounce the
evil doer nothing is more difficult than
to understand him
[Music]
yes that's right love should come before
logic only then will man come to
understand the meaning of life
for broad understanding and deep feeling
you need pain and suffering
suffering is part and parcel of
extensive intelligence and a feeling
heart
wealth is the number of things one can
do without
if everything on earth were rational
nothing would happen
the cleverest of all in my opinion is
the man who calls himself a fool at
least once a month
[Music]
a hundred suspicions don't make a proof
it takes something more than
intelligence to act intelligently
[Music]
only one thing matters one thing to be
able to dare
[Music]
only the heart knows how to find what is
precious
[Music]
to love another person is to see them as
god intended them to be
there is immeasurably more left inside
than what comes out in words
he who masters the grey every day is a
hero
[Music]
to think too much is a disease
what is hell i maintain that it is the
suffering of being unable to
love the greatest happiness is to know
the source of unhappiness
[Music]
lying to ourselves is more deeply
ingrained than lying to others
[Music]
i think the devil doesn't exist but man
has created him he has created him in
his own image and likeness
[Music]
pain and suffering are always inevitable
for a large intelligence and a deep
heart
[Music]
i did not bow down to you i bow down to
all the suffering of humanity
if he has a conscience he will suffer
for his mistake
that will be his punishment as well as
the prison
[Music]
to go wrong in one's own way is better
than to go right in someone else's
[Music]
i say let the world go to hell but i
should always have my tea
[Music]
man only likes to count his troubles he
doesn't calculate his happiness
[Music]
but how could you live and have no story
to tell
[Music]
taking a new step uttering a new word is
what people fear most
[Music]
much unhappiness has come into the world
because of bewilderment and things left
unsaid
right or wrong it's very pleasant to
break something from time to time
[Music]
beware of women who tell you too many
flattering words
their mouths spew flattery and flattery
is already a lie
[Music]
do
[Music]
you